>> Tucker: JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO THE NAVY ADMITTED FOR
THE FIRST TIME THAT SEVERAL
UFO VIDEOS WERE REAL MEANING
THEY SHOW ACTUAL AREA
PHENOMENON THAT SO FAR THE
PENTAGON CANNOT EXPLAIN.
NOW UFO EXPLANATION GROUP
SAYS THEY HAVE FOUND
MATERIAL THAT COULD BE
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE OF UFOs.
LOUISE [INAUDIBLE] SUPER
STAR ACADEMY OF ARRESTS AND
SCIENCE HEADED THE
PENTAGON'S OFFICE.
STAR OF THE HISTORY CHANNEL
"UNIDENTIFIED."
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THIS
MATERIAL AND WHY COULD IT
SHED LIGHT ON THE QUESTION
OF WHAT UFOs MIGHT BE.
>> SURE, OUR COMPANY OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF HAS
ACTUALLY OBTAINED QUITE A
BIT OF MATERIAL.
LET ME FIRST PREFACE BY
SAYING SOME OF THAT MATERIAL
THAT'S PROVIDENCE IS FRANKLY
HEARSAY WHILE OTHER OF THE
PROFNTS OF SOME OF
PROVNTS OF SOME OF
PROVIDS OF SOME OF
PROVIDENOF SOME OF
PROVIDENCE SOME OF
PROVIDENCE OOME OF
PROVIDENCE OFME OF
PROVIDENCE OF S OF
PROVIDENCE OF SOMF
PROVIDENCE OF SOME OF THIS
OTHER MATERIAL HAS BEEN
SUBSTANTIATED.
RESULT 34589LY IN THE
PROCESS OF ANALYZING THIS
PHYSICAL PROPERTIES,
CHEMICAL OR MOLECULAR
PROPERTIES AND THEN
ULTIMATELY ATOMIC
PROPERTIES.
AND IT'S REALLY AT THAT
POINT WE'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE
SOME SORT OF DEFINITIVE
CONCLUSION, KEEPING IN MIND
THAT WE STILL HAVE TO FOLLOW
THE SCIENTIFIC PROCESS AND
METHODS AND AT THE SAME TIME
HAVE PEER REVIEW.
IT'S NOT JUST AS SIMPLE AS
COMING OUT AND SAYING HEY,
LOOK WHAT WE FOUND THERE IS
A LOT OF WORK THAT STILL
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE THAT
RIGHT AND BE CHALLENGED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: WHY DO YOU THINK
THIS MATERIAL MIGHT BE
CONNECTED TO UFOs?
>> WITHOUT GETTING INTO A
LOT OF DETAIL RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE FRANKLY IT'S TOO
SPECULATIVE FOR ME AT THIS
POINT TO SAY WHY I THINK
SOMETHING.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S
GOING TO BE WHAT THE
ANALYSIS TELLS US.
AND IF YOU HAVE, FOR
EXAMPLE, INTERESTING ISOTOPE
PICK RATIOS THAT ARE NOT
NORMALLY FOUND LET'S SAY ON
THIS PLANET, THEN YOU HAVE
TO SCRATCH YOUR HEAD AND A
EITHER ENGINEERED THAT WAY
OR B CAME FROM SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND ULTIMATELY THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO FIND
OUT.
>> Tucker: THESE ARE
MATERIALS BROUGHT TO YOU BY
PEOPLE WHO SAY THIS IS AT
THE SITE OF A UFO INCIDENT
OR CRASH?
>> IN SOME CASES, YES.
UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T
ELABORATE TOO MUCH WITH SOME
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS.
WE DO HAVE NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS.
IT'S FROM VARIOUS SOURCES
BOTH PRIVATE AND
GOVERNMENTAL.
>> Tucker: IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING I HOPE YOU WILL COME
BACK AS YOU GET TO THE